it should I suppose have come as no
surprise it fell to veteran actress and
Miss Marple star Dame Angela Lansbury to
detect a shred of sense and logic out of
the sexual harassment scandal that's
engulf Hollywood Westminster and
elsewhere Dame Angela our sprightly 92
by the way this week said and I quote
there are two sides of the coin we have
to own up to the fact that women since
time immemorial have gone out of their
way to make themselves attractive and
unfortunately it has backfired on us and
this is where we are today and she
concludes we must sometimes take blame
women I really do think that now before
feminists take up arms to attack her and
probably me consider carefully what
she's saying
no one is condoning inappropriate
suggestions touching or behavior while
women have every right to dress in tight
tops skimpy skirts thigh length boots or
in Rachel's case like Kim jong-in from
North Korea
they shouldn't be surprised if it
attracts acceptable attention from men
surely you don't need to be a super
sleuth to work that out thank you for
drawing attention to my boy list which I
wore deliberately in order to provoke on
this topic all right I think it's
problematic to say that if women dress
sexy they are presenting themselves as
sex objects and in inviting unwanted
sexual tensions or even worse violence
that's not what she said well no in fact
she did something else in this speech
which she basically said you you you're
sort of inviting trouble she really I
mean it's a should women be prepared for
this
no and no they should not have to be
there's no excuse so that is what she
said all she's saying is if you dress in
at her a guy is going to be attractive
that doesn't mean I can touch you that
doesn't mean I could make inappropriate
suggestions but I haven't going to be
attracted to someone women make
themselves attractive and then they look
attractive she was making a link between
the way women look and the way they
dress and the kind of sexual abuse that
has been proliferating or at least our
awareness of it has been she's not here
to defend us of it's awful to say we
can't make ourselves look as attractive
as possible without being not
found and raped she's saying all she is
saying is if you make yourself the woman
makes herself a man is probably going to
be touched again because I thought that
I couldn't get my head around the last
one I did you know what knocked down and
rape okay Nick Ferrari is always right
so we need to look mister it's a line
underneath it's awful to say we can't
make ourselves look as attractive as
possible without being knocked down and
raped it's all it's awful to say yes but
what she's suggesting is if you make
yourself as attractive as possible you
run the risk of being knocked down and
raped you know if you invert the second
if you take change the genders isn't it
weird we couldn't be sitting here having
a debate that say if men go out dress
make looking their selves looking sexy
and attractive they can't complain if
they just receive unwarranted scandal
that's been in Hollywood oh do you not
think that that is a little bit out of
control the sexual harassment sketch I
made with agree with because I think
there is an incredible cull of men but
for tiny offenses I'm sending a text or
sending a text or hand on knee you know
I think women from time immemorial have
dealt with that quite world I think it
was the rape comment was a bit clumsy
and a bit unfortunate however I got what
she was trying to say to him what she's
saying is that women dress in a certain
way and present themselves in a certain
way women you know when are you whether
you want to admit it or not women
exploit their youth their beauty the way
they look and they exploited by
addressing in a certain way and looking
in a certain way and and yes that can
attract met and you can't pretend that
by that by dressing in a provocative way
in that by wearing really short skirts
you're not doing it to attract members
of the opposite sex because you are now
you know George Lindsey Kushner she was
she was presiding over a case early this
remember her she says girls are
perfectly entitled to drink themselves
to the ground which should be aware
people who are potential defendants to
read gravitate towards girls who have
been drinking it is the same thing women
have to take responsibility they have it
they have a certain they have a duty to
take responsibility from said that's not
to say that that they deserve to be
raped because they wear provocative
clothing but you have to be aware that
if you do you're going to attract a
rival in the
your disability shaking your head I feel
so strongly about this I think I know
that none of you and Angela Lansbury is
not trying to say that women invite rape
I know no I know you're not saying that
and so it's important to say that I'm
not saying any of you are saying that
what she's saying that however this
these kind of remarks which do make a
link to the way women dress and sexual
harassment sexual violence are taking
place in a context where we live in a
rape culture 1659 or women one in five
of them have experience in this country
sexual assault one-third of young women
have experienced some kind of sexual
assault during their childhood this is
not some niche issue women who I'm sure
most of you agree have not behaved in
any way reprehensibly are experiencing
regularly unwanted sexual tension
attention sexual assault and rape and
this isn't about what anyone is wearing
this is about power this is about a
society where men are using power with
the judges women do their personal
conduct and and the way that they
experience this power structure the
difficult effort just for Barry Michelle
if a girl does drink herself into the
ground should she be aware of the
potential consequences there are lots of
reasons why do you have any
responsibility for your behavior there
there is nothing a woman can do so that
that would make her more responsible for
being a victim of any kind of sexual
thought in my view and I and I just
bring in what right cries to say about
this because it's important they say as
well it's a deeply unhelpful myth that
rape and other forms of sexual violence
are caused or provoked by women's
sexuality or attractiveness and I don't
agree with that today you've got a
daughter if when she's a few years older
she went out at night wearing a very
short skirt what would you say to her I
think that we as women we are
responsible for ourselves but that what
would you call a turret the thing I
worry about for my daughter is that
nothing she will do is going to make out
out of risk of some kind of sexual
assault is prevalent regardless of how
women behave I feel like I need to
caveat what I'm about to say with the
with the fact that I don't suggest that
anyone deserves to be touched abused or
anything I need to make that caveat
so nobody is responsible if they are you
know if I'm abused in any way it's not
my responsibility is from perpetrators
fault . now now that I said that caveat
I'll make a few points when I was on the
apprentice and I won the apprentice I
which is a business show this second I
became available to the media I was
inundated with offers of a lot of money
to take my clothes off to pose in
underwear bikinis whatever a lot of
money by various different publications
I made a very considered choice to say
no no matter what some of money that I
never wanted to have photographs in
bikinis lingerie et cetera because I
work in business and I work particularly
in technology which wrongly at the
moment is dominated by men so very often
I am pretty much one of the only women
in my in my meetings I don't want any of
those men to have seen my breasts my
backside because I feel that puts me in
a disadvantaged position when I'm trying
to have serious professional business
condom it conversation diversity but no
I'm not I'm talking about is there a
link between how one dress is and how
one is reacted to based on I really
think you're saying show but I really
think it's a woman to separate this
completely from the issue of sexual
harassment sexual assault you know we
all of us who talk to young women would
advise them to dress professionally to
carry themselves in that way that has
nothing to do with your responsibility
if you are ever the victim of somebody
was also talking about but about a bit
more than clothes maybe she was talking
about women who chose to sleep with men
in Hollywood for a reason it was an
arrangement you know Marilyn Monroe was
asked if she slept with her bosses she
said of course it's expected it's my
sense about men what because women the
right to say no to these people if you
if they want a part in a movie and if
they know the way to get it is to sleep
with whoever's directing it they go yes
or no yes I will oh no I won't they make
a decision it's a transaction if that's
not necessary it's just a nuts way women
are affected by the unequal distribution
of power in our society and you know I
feel sorry for Angela Lansbury because
there are many women who I think have
genuinely been conditioned to believe
that the kind of treatment is their own
fault you know there was that American
gymnast Gabby Douglas who said in a
Twitter that that women have to take
some responsibility for their sexual
abuse by the way they dress and carry
themselves it then emerge she was one of
the hundred 25 gymnast who'd been abused
by the team doctor and you know women
often internalize that that victim
blaming and that's why I think it is
very important to have the clear line in
the discussion between which is how
women behave one way those are certain
things that maybe wanting to don't want
to do if you want to avoid that
don't don't dress in a certain way I
mean it's it's common sense of it is
crazing I think it's generational
injuries why Angela Lansbury age 92 says
it Booker but now no age and at no stage
visit ever you see this aside she's seen
it